all right Christopher you've got the
quick setup here special cars bonded if
you will we do we do so Dana White
according to TMZ sports says he's a day
or two from securing this private island
I won't be able to get international
fighters all of them into United States
so I have a private island I'm gonna fly
them there and do the fights from there
and I kick it over to fellow Syracuse
Orangemen
area host of the Ariel Helwani MMA show
and so much more ESPN's MMA snap show
proud father of three as he says in his
in his Twitter bio kind enough to double
up as a Chris Brockman News
correspondent right here Ariel Helwani
how are you Ariel
to congratulate you and our fellow
orange men across this great country and
world that was on this day back in 2003
that young Carmelo Anthony led the
orange to their national championships
and Jerry McNamara who's six
three-pointers in the first half can you
say can you say Mazel Tov to a guy named
Jerry McNamara great point
Passover does start tomorrow night so
maybe we just pass over that how are you
I trust everybody as well and good and
you're in your world I hope we're good
knock on wood and you know again as long
as we're able to be here we'll be here
so how is this not a fighting fire fest
Ariel walk me through what you're
hearing about this plan other than the
fact that could obviously be very well
funded but a private island creating
your own fight world that is that is
something Ariel yes in a circus over the
years but this has exceeded even my own
expectations there's kind of two stories
happening at the same time here rich
because there's one story where the UFC
has this event scheduled for April 18
which is not this Saturday next Saturday
and they have been hella bent on putting
on this pay-per-view event and from what
I'm hearing they're on the verge of
finalizing a deal some
on the west coast of the United States
likely California on a tribal land where
they will basically set up shop at this
location and put on a multitude of
events like it will now become sort of
like a makeshift UFC headquarters if you
will and they will put on a bunch of
events for American based fighters April
18th April 25th May 2nd May 9th etc etc
and they're already working on logistics
and getting you know a chef there and
all this stuff and it's just going to be
like their own private arena and then
yesterday Dana White tell TMZ as you
mentioned that you know he's close to
securing this island to both events for
the international fighters because of
course the international players won't
be able to come here to the United
States now I have not talked to a single
fighter or manager who has told me that
they have heard this from the UFC like
this was all news to everyone when Dana
said it also worth noting every single
fighter and manager that is scheduled to
compete not only on the April 18th or
25th cards have not been told where
these fights are happening just yet so
the OSI is keeping everything very close
to the best I feel a lot more confident
in the April 18 fight happening at this
location in California as opposed to
this island I think that's going to be a
little more involved but they are
hell-bent on putting on these events and
forging on and being the first one to be
up and running for whatever reason and
Dana feels confident right now that it's
going to happen well look obviously
having a captive audience for such a
popular sport and UFC is one of the most
popular entities on the planet that
makes sense to try and get that up and
running but wouldn't people have to be
14 day quarantine right now to hold
something or have been over the weekend
to hold something on the 18th of April
yes and there's so much more like my
head is spinning thinking about this
because you're not just talking about
the fight itself or themselves you're
talking about the training camps right
these guys and girls aren't training
alone they're training with coaches you
know they have to prepare you can't just
train in your house by yourself on the
treadmill for fight and so by virtue of
that you're doing essentially everything
that the government is telling us not to
do right and by the way I've talked to a
multitude of fighters
all said to me we want to fight this is
the only way I make money the only way I
can provide for my family I am very
happy that the UFC is going through all
of this to try to make these fights
happen because I need to make money I've
already invested in training camp
coaches etc so on the one hand I'm
conflicted because if you just look at
the news everything that is out there
every sporting organization every
non-essential business is shut down
right there they're not doing anything
right now so why is Emma May above all
this it feels very weird doesn't sit
well with me on the other hand I respect
the fighters greatly and I feel for them
and they want to make money as you some
other people who are losing out right
now and so I don't want to you know over
their parade and try to stop us but
there's a mix of emotions it's very
strange yeah of course since the one
would think the variant assist
antithesis of social distancing is
submissions right and this right here
goes a gauge everything like that I
think in the frame forget what the thing
itself the corner man and and the
referee the official who's supposed to
like check you up before we go to the
cage and the cup medics putting the
Bazley like everything is is wrong about
this like we're breaking every single
rule that's out there right now and on
top of that this happens in California
like California is in a state of
emergency lockdown stay right now so so
where are these people that are going to
come and officiate these events and and
right away they're putting on these
events and tribal lines which don't have
to adhere to the state athletic
commission regulations so now you're
risking upsetting the conference by
commissioner the badge is like you're
basically going through we're basically
going back to 1997 when the UFC couldn't
get sanctioned and here's the whole
event since up in Alabama just to put on
events and make ends meet like that's
what's happening here alright last one
for you Ariel I guess then the the
island really was something that nobody
had heard about and that maybe he's just
I don't even know what the question is
like what why how we and we don't even
know the where we just know the that we
just know the island right we just yeah
that's why we just know that there's an
island you know back in the data was
questioned called Bo dogfight and they
help
it's on an island in Costa Rica and so
this is what I'm saying like I'm getting
deja vu of the in the early days what
makes martial arts the Wild West it is a
mixed martial arts but you said that I
had a bunch of fighters and managers
tell me like reach out to me and be like
what Island what's going on with this
island I don't know like what you guys
should be able to find out better than
me like what do you want me to do but I
don't know anything about this you know
this is all very new to everyone well
you you know everything about everything
Aaron let's that's why maybe maybe maybe
I've got a theory here you follow me
here like you know obviously you and and
Dana back in the day got off on somewhat
of a wrong foot I remember one of the
first times you came on this show is
when you had a credential removed we
talked about it maybe this island isn't
really at all to soul fights it's to get
you there and then leave you there no
I'm not going near any one of these
islands because last time I saw this
documentary about this music festival in
Ireland it turned out to be a disaster
where the cheese sandwiches Arielle
actually thanks to the call IRL and
congrats again on everything that you're
doing with ESPN and how you have grown
your brand it has been remarkable very
pleased anytime right back at you that's
Ariel Helwani here on the Rich Eisen
show